you got my legs straight toes pointed
like this see like that
oh oh my gosh we're not gonna do this
Noggin all right a Michigan fire chief
is caught on camera asking for a lawyer
after he's caught drinking and driving I
feel like I feel like I just need to
wait for a lawyer you wanna wait for a
lawyer fantastic you're gonna be placed
under arrest put your hands behind your
back okay the arrest happened on August
29th in Dearborn Michigan just outside
of Detroit that's where officers pulled
over a driver for speeding going 60
miles per hour in a 40 mile per hour
Zone and for swerving his vehicle in the
road
[Music]
did not laugh
body camera video shows an officer
approached the vehicle where the driver
is heard slurring his words oh all
supported General Heights Police
Department do you have any idea how fast
you're going to do
all right try it too fast uh as hard as
us too fast officials later determined
they'd pulled over Joseph Murray chief
of the Dearborn fire department Fire
Chief Joseph Murray Here video shows the
responding officer asked Murray whether
he's had any drinks before testing him
about the time the drink tonight sir
yeah I I've had a couple of beers for
sure how many beers a couple beers uh
three or four three or four yeah okay
how long ago do you have those what's
that how long ago do you have those
beers
uh
within a couple hours all right what
time do you think it is right now it's
over without looking at the clock and
you already looked in the clock I'm
sorry you're good all right have you had
anything to drink or eat in the last 15
minutes
uh in the last 15 minutes yep no okay so
go ahead and shut the vehicle off for me
yes sir
what is up out of the vehicle when
Murray steps out of the vehicle his
slurred speech continues
got anything on you that we need to know
about no I have nothing all right go
ahead and uh pick us up over here turn
around real quick
put your hands up here yes sir
what are you drinking at
what's that where are you drinking at
tonight
uh we're in uh yeah
excuse me Bruce baby Brews
I mean you have four beers
um
four or five all right it's then that
officers ask Murray Point Blank whether
he's intoxicated because I mean let's
just be honest you're you're absolutely
ripped
right I don't you're hammered drunk
you can barely speak you can barely
stand up
okay come on over here after that field
sobriety tests begin
next an officer explains the directions
for another test
can you walk in a straight line
oh yeah yeah absolutely
one big step back a big step back
what's up one step back a big one yeah
oh perfect what I want you to do I want
you to put your right foot in front of
your left foot touch your heel to your
toe just like this
stand just like this
right in front of it though man on the
side
perfect now don't move oh don't don't
touch your car
all right great Flats close that's
really close all right when I tell you
you're gonna take nine steps in a
straight line you're gonna touch your
heel to your toe on each step you're
counting each step out loud pull it just
like this one two three all the way to
nine on your nine seven
all right I want you to put your feet
together arms down by your side just
like a stand just like this feet
together like this once again feet
together perfect don't move when I tell
you to You're Gonna you're gonna lift
one foot off the ground approximately
six inches you're gonna count out loud
so that I can hear you it's going just
like this your point guard straight 1001
1002 one thousand three one thousand
four one thousand five you're gonna keep
going until I tell you to stop if you
put your foot down before I tell you to
please pick it back up and resume
counting where you left off all right on
out loud slow I can hear you and you're
gonna keep going until I tell you to
stop if you understand that thank you
all right do you have any questions
a little more to it than that but do you
understand what I demonstrated to you
all right give me your best shot but
when Maria attempts to perform the test
he loses balance
she got my legs straight toes pointed
like this see like that oh oh my gosh
we're not gonna do that chicken fucking
Noggin all right that's when officers
ask Marie to take a breathalyzer test
through slurred speech he seemingly says
he wants to wait for an attorney all
right Joseph
we already established in the last 15
minutes you've had nothing to eat or
drink smoke Burpee don't put in your
mouth all right state of Michigan
requires a pound request a police
officer you submit your preliminary
broadcast Philly reducer results and
find the Civil infraction
up to a hundred dollars do you
understand that
yes sir all right open your mouth you
can tell
perfect
there's a PBT open up it's like a
balloon blow as hard as you can
I mean no I mean I'm not like a another
foreign seconds later he repeats this
more clearly after that he's taken into
cast
you don't want to take that
I don't understand where you're at
because I think you're intoxicated I
think you've got too much to drink today
this will just kind of give us a rough
estimate of exactly where kind of that
number's at okay
Murray was arrested and taken into
custody and released several hours later
he's since been placed on administrative
leave from the fire department reporting
for long crime Network I'm Sierra
Gillespie